cette manette de gaming est complètement
folle c'est la Rogue reikiri pro
nouvelle manette avec un petit écran en
haut alors vous avez des LEDs vous
n'avez personnalisé les couleurs
directement dans Armoric white mais le
truc qui est génial c'est que vous avez
des petits boutons en haut pour venir
totalement personnaliser l'écran et
l'expérience tu peux avoir différents
profils je peux avoir un fond d'écran
par exemple ici j'ai appuyer j'ai un
profil donc là je peux choisir mon
profil de joueur profiter un profil 2
profil 3 qui permet venir de
personnaliser totalement l'expérience au
niveau de la configuration de votre
manette pareil également au niveau des
fonds d'écran je peux avoir le choix
entre différents fonds Rock 2 rock 3 et
compagnie je laisse appuyer je valide et
ça vient totalement personnaliser ici
mon affichage c'est juste génial j'aime
beaucoup en plus vous avez énormément de
boutons un peu tous les côtés alors les
temples gamer c'est pas forcément moi
vous expliquer comment venir jouer avec
mais je la trouve vraiment superbe très
maniable très belle c'est une fois de
plus une manette qu'on retrouve ici au
CES avec Asus c'est la Rogue Rai qui rit
pro perso j'adore dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez dans les commentaires